five four three two
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
extravaganza bonanza whoa yes yes it is
us ethan and ela klein back with another
episode we are back joined by of course
producer dan intern in and sound lad
Zach what a terrific game we've got and
I thank all of you you're my trifa
cooper troopers out there who join us on
this beautiful Friday we've got a lot to
get to a lot to say first of all thank
you to our sponsors expressvpn and
stamps.com yeah how are you feeling on
this beautiful glorious God's Friday I
am entering the last trimester of the
pregnancy yeah meaning three months left
and also meaning I'm starting to suffer
yeah and I can't fit into any clothes
yeah you got this your pant the pants
ooh you are crazy you got like this fat
girdle are you wearing it now
down the way yeah no not the underwear
the dirt no anyway you was getting big
as a house it's free you can't hide in a
sand pit show just that you don't have
to don't lift your shirt but just to see
like when she walks around it's like and
well that's terrific
it always looks nice and big on camera
for that shirt hides it well yeah but I
feel like you could give lessons on how
to hide the pregnancy like you're such a
pro I swear I forget that you're
pregnant it's because I don't like when
I'm wearing tight clothes I never did so
that's just my immediate it's my style
mmm I don't even own anything really
tired all right yeah so well there you
have it guys from the ELA herself now
first up I want to get a little light
heart because as you could tell from the
title of this episode we've got some
stuff to discuss
we watched the Michael Jackson
documentary leaving Neverland
we also wash our Kelly have a breakdown
those lots to say about that I'm looking
forward to discussing but we've got some
stuff to get started with as Zack found
it
wait this isn't it oh this is the cheese
slice I thought this was the the
Instagram masseuse where's that at the
top I don't see it some there's some
black oh that's what it is what weird on
me black and blue
Zack yeah how did you find this um just
scrolling through Instagram fusion
healing so this really shocked us she
expect to feel and expect to hear as
blockage stagnation releases from the
body they channel through me as a vessel
to the earth so she's giving this woman
a really intense is there something
there is sound yeah there's none I hear
it I was just quiet at the beginning so
she's getting in there and then I think
we got it really that's what's up man so
in theory I guess is that she's
channeling the bad energy and then it
comes out and burps yeah she's like
grounding the chakras you know there's
some dudes with like burp fetishes like
yo can you pull that on my face yeah
that was I would be like that juicy not
burping
it's actually it looks nice but she's
yeah and I was like damn what's that
what is she doing I'm trying to do that
then she just lays a real nasty stinky
one she doesn't really even look away
like
like if you rip like the prayers
would it work if it was a guy oh if it
was a male masseuse absolutely not no
you have to be pretty young girl to pull
that off what if I channeled dark energy
through farts just rip a fat one sorry
babies just the dark arts it's just the
dark energy channeling through me you're
looking for some fusion healing so do
people expect it yeah it's part of the
whack go for that's her expelling the
you know dark energy so I would love to
start that's almost like a Nathan for
you Plaza where you can pick a masseuse
we chose it through their ass or through
their mouth I just love the idea of a
masseuse ripping a fat ass I was
thinking maybe a curb bit the glare he
goes in for a massage right yeah there's
a lot to do with this have you guys
heard about the throwing cheese on your
bait and your your newborn child's face
I kind of did but I have no idea why Oh
what let me introduce you guys this is
the video I saw on Instagram that
started it when you toss a slice of
processed cheese onto your baby's face
so this is a trend on facebook I guess
an Instagram a me a sweet innocent child
that I love how about being humiliated
seal are you watching this yeah why the
kid looks horrified they're like out
there like they're like here's what
we're gonna do we have a new meme it's
super awesome what this new meme is is
get let's get as close to child abuse as
we can be able to monetize it yeah I
mean that's yeah that's bad so Ian who
started this why I think they just think
it's funny and they got Facebook like so
they're like let's go now Ian did some
work for us in Tulsa
this compilation you put together I was
just scrolling a think cheese challenge
hashtag on Instagram and there's a lot a
lot of people doing this and what kind
of video did you see any videos that
shock to you I mean other than the
obvious like the whole thing is shocking
but was there any worse than others
well like the ones that had a couple
thousand likes the baby would laugh but
if you went deep and found like five or
six likes they really smacked that baby
with that cheese they throw the cheese
hard yeah yeah they nailed that baby who
is this person that we were just watched
I feel bad watching this yeah that guy
dude what's wrong with you I'm about to
have a kid I can't imagine doing this to
my beautiful innocent loving pure child
you're gonna throw a piece of all things
American cheese it's like humiliating
them right out right at the gate look at
this poor kid they start laughing at it
hello why did you do this to me I hate
this person I hate everyone who does
this yeah this people support despite
his pants all right here we go cheese
challenge take one alright here we go
it's a cheese challenge get me a pack of
smokes yeah you can't just kid it's like
punching someone in the stomach be like
I'm just kidding No
right here where did you behind this
who's behind this did Dan just sneak
that in right now when he came in you
had this in your pocket the whole time
how long were you buying this I can't
tell you wow yeah you hit my head here
don't move oh I'm gonna choose you hey
ela I love you
oh [ __ ] all right you want to choose me
it's hard for respect to these parents
now I got a small target too with the
little baby face I wonder if this is a
game Michael Jackson play it at home
catch the cheese that's what's up
I kissed you yes got him now you got to
eat it don't waste food confirm it
doesn't feel good I don't know any
quality we get the idea why is that even
it's not why don't you just throw a
piece of poop on it's like white
American cheese why stop there finding
it funny just kind of place it on the
kids face almost and it's like oh that
was very forceful yeah like smacks like
that it's like come on yeah so this lady
pretty much threw it a full-force like
almost like this lady is getting out
some hate she has towards her baby like
is that what's going on here they're
like I got this American cheese
challenge I hate my baby I'm gonna throw
it at its face like look how hard she
throws it that's unreasonable
she's the girls like mom I trust you and
this is how serial killers are born
mm-hmm
you can see them on the on the couch of
their therapist 20 years later you know
kids have a sense of humor and they'll
usually laugh at like slapstick comedy
whatever funny faces and this kids are
not even smiling
no they're shocked what is wrong with
you the ultimate betrayal I am so
freakin I'm excited I'm nervous I'm
scared I can't believe I'm gonna be a
dad in three months Wow yeah damn
and give us got this huge stomach and
there's like a baby in it and it's
kicking all the time and yeah the weird
thing is the father is that I don't Ella
has a much stronger connection already
to the baby because
I just forget she's pregnant sometimes
because she hides it so well and the
baby is cooking all day right like for
you it's very real
I don't forget it yeah you're kicking
right now no this morning yes
every time I everyday when I wake up
it's like lots of movements mmm I mean I
cannot imagine what that's like to have
a creature rolling around in here yeah
wow that's incredible that's so crazy
and then also just that I the concept
that it's like it's half me half you
yeah that we just created this baby
inside of you it's so weird
yeah and he's gonna come out and he's
gonna look like me you just can't
understand it it's just it's like it's
just so unreal it's like magic I'm
loving your kid almost in a way is like
self-love because everybody has to be
humble and they're like because with
their kid they're like you're so smart
you're amazing you're better you're
almost talking to yourself in that sense
right it's a way of loving yourself I
guess
acceptable I don't know yeah I don't
know obviously but it's weird because
it's us and I don't think so I think
it's just unconditional love cuz it's
things like so pure yeah and cute but it
looks like us is that crazy
I think it's gonna look laughs your eyes
one of us might look like you this
thing's gonna look it's gonna look like
both of us you can have your eyes and
he's gonna have my my mug that only a
mother could love and well little
Theodore I'm already excited it's like
take him to Disneyland and yeah take him
to petting zoos fracking the heck it's
gonna be so fun I'm excited my sister
gave birth this way yeah congratulations
how many is that three it's our third
child and yeah it's so crazy like you
see her before pregnant and all but then
the moment after you see like a real
baby and that came out of her I know
it's so Wow
so well before you mean got pregnant I
was like
how is a baby gonna come out of you
because you're so skinny and your figure
is so small no wondering well no but
your figure has accommodated like your
body and everything is accommodating to
a level where I was like really
surprised just to see how much your
bodies change and now I'm just like oh
yeah mm-hmm you got a you got a baby
rearing body the body just does thick in
other words you you look great though
Game of Thrones Season eight trailers
out is that worth watching or is it just
like whatever
it looks great I'm excited for Game of
Thrones super soon I'm not very excited
I'm excited for the show I still haven't
watched the trailer and I I'm not a
trailer person I don't care about it so
it's pretty hype well the thing trailers
are inherently if you can avoid trailers
you're better off because it's like all
spoilers all misdirection yeah all
misinformation it gets you excited I'm
already excited I don't know why I don't
know how they're gonna wrap that show up
in like eight episodes though not even I
think six of for real yeah they're all
like super long like so they're super
long it's practically like six movies
okay we're there like an hour and a half
yeah exactly
I wonder why did they do it like that
because they could have melted for an
extra three episodes yeah well I think
cuz um they got the same budget each
year and so if they do less episodes
they can spend more on each one yeah
battles all over the place and all that
kind of stuff
wow-whee is all I have to say I mean I
definitely love the hour-and-a-half
episode I'm all-in but there's a shot of
Jon in ten years walking towards two
dragons in your life Jon's gonna ride
that mother-effer and they're gonna bow
I didn't like he wrote his on okay okay
listen if my aunt looked like that I'd
rather drag them up there
my aunt's are they do not look like that
it looks amazing
it's gonna be a freaking blast when the
show started I wasn't so much into it
it kind of seemed like soap opera yeah
cheesiness but I liked it no yeah it's a
tear resistant yeah I've read the books
and the Moot and the show now is so much
further than the books I don't even I
don't even remember that the books are a
thing oh yeah Ethan is one and and your
whole family I don't know if everyone
else is also I don't know but I felt
there's a lot of people that come here
probably Ethan is the kind of person who
knows all the names and someone possible
yes oh yeah I've read all the books
twice sorry
that's crazy Dan yeah okay well when the
show first started I read through him
and then I was about like a year ago I I
just started again I don't know why
they're great that's why I know they're
good reads yeah when you guys see
someone on the screen you're like oh
yeah that's that guy who was this
annoying guy talking over the entire
episode explaining no that's Rhaegar
Rhaegar was murdered by Robert that's a
battle of the whatever to you know that
when Robert killed Rhaegar battle of the
the Trident yes that's right he
destroyed him with his giant mallet
right to the chest and the ruby came off
and went to the river right then right
although it might not have been him
because rubies are always associated
with Glamour's and illusions in wait no
that was yeah but that was his armor
that was his armor that Brian I have to
wear but I'll get out the series
associated with allusions so maybe he's
gonna lie give me a break he's mad he's
mance rayder nice Wow
Wow but the trailer did show that the
Hound is alive he was brought back to
life we knew that in the book mm-hmm
sorry spoilers it's a [ __ ] show
that's been out for years if you haven't
read it then who cares no but when it's
in the trailer we knew he was alive from
the last season write the book diverges
in such a weird way because I don't know
if this is a spoiler but I just come on
it's been so long if you're not gonna
the book is so much different than the
mmm yeah but so the priest of fire
Ryle or she brings back the mom back to
life in the books yeah really
and the mom starts like a bandit Starks
my Catelyn Stark right yes correct and
she starts some crazy like that's cold
yeah going around him and she's like wow
and so that would that never happened so
she's kind of like crazy when she comes
back well she's like a demon yeah but
yeah she's definitely not the old
Catelyn lady they call her lady what
they call her down Lady Stoneheart yeah
Lady Stoneheart it's pretty cool it's a
little on the nose to be honest and then
also the Hound was reanimated right
there The Hound no you're thinking of
the mountain not yet no I thought I
thought he died and he was brought back
oh well he was brought back in the show
wasn't he yeah the hounds back in the
show yeah he's not back in the books
okay so it's like yeah at this point
they they really are just different
things yes fine you know yeah they're
both good in different ways yeah one
will end one won't
so I'm excited that's less than a month
away so excited hey everybody I'm gonna
sleep with a kid what did the little kid
say in Michael Jackson's bed we'll get
to that later
so you guys know that I'm passionate
about awful food on Instagram I am loved
it very much it's a it's a hobby of mine
I can spend hours on Instagram just
looking at the food 90% of it is really
bald ass looking like barbecue and stuff
that I love there's a lot of this
Turkish food that fascinates me because
it's so different and and it looks
amazing but there's a lot of really just
awful [ __ ] and it cracks me up and
especially because a lot of it is
extremely popular
here is one example that I recently came
across okay now this is a perfectly
delicious looking burger what better
thing to do than to literally take a
diary over I mean what the f is this are
you Fred is not my assuming it's some
kind of cheese thought for the audio
listeners it's just a giant burger and
they're just completely covering it bun
and all with Aria I don't know it's I
mean it's a really beautiful completed
whole burger perfectly edible and
delicious looking so the guy takes a
huge ball how I supposed to pull the
cheese sauce and and I'm dumps it on it
not a little bit he dumped he covers it
so I was like wow this is really
disgusting that went from edible to
inedible and I love all hype the guys it
looks amazing on camera no it doesn't
looks absolutely foul so that was one
hope you guys enjoy that did you enjoyed
that ELA I am Joey hating on it
Ian did you enjoy that video yes very
much thank you and appreciate know and
how are you in we love hearing from you
intern talk to me tell me a little bit
of something there's not much to tell
really
yes I kept in marvel last night oh I
liked it I thought it was good you know
I noticed the phenomenon about Captain
Marvel rotten tomato and I noticed this
on Metacritic and I'm - being everywhere
critics liked it the users are like two
or three like they hated it and I was
like why they despise the discrepancy do
you have any idea in uh yeah it's people
who are boycotting the movie because
they disagreed with something brie
Larson said last year oh so it's a
political thing yeah yeah it is God come
on what did she say do you know horrible
movie said something about how the
amount of white guys in the reviewing
community was disproportionate - it was
like only white males and something
about that hmm and reviewing movies yeah
and we should probably burn our house
down furious probably the user reviews
and we should probably boycott
everything she ever making for the rest
of eternity
I don't know what she's talking about it
might be right I don't know or she might
be wrong
she's my I don't know breather item was
the girl in Scott Pilgrim right yeah I
just hate how it's like when somebody
has an opinion that you disagree with
it's like I remember from a year ago
I'm gonna demo you and also I'm gonna
find out where you live and I'm going to
chill out
but everyone watch the Queen move it I
had no problem with that's what I'm
saying
the hip people live like these the
people have like tunnel vision it's like
yeah oh we loved Bohemian Rhapsody we
want to give it all the rewards and
malli relic or whatever his name is that
[ __ ] serial killer on me he's at the
best fabulous we love him also it was
directed by a known pedophile
but oh we love it it's gonna win all the
awards it was directed by a known
pedophile uh what's his name Brian uh
what was his name banger Brian singer
alleged alleged don't sue us
Oh known did I say known I'm an alleged
highly alleged the allegations are
outlined in a documentary got him no but
for real I don't I don't know what she
said maybe it was stupid but me my god
so she says one stupid thing you're
gonna try to like [ __ ] give me a
brother have to do with the movie yeah
was it like come on like how many people
work on a movie as if it's just her
project if I had to guess it's gonna be
a just a run-of-the-mill Marvel movie
anyways you know name yeah all about the
same quality you know I was I was a
little hyped I thought it looked
interesting but I don't know that I'm
gonna see do you recommend watching it
in if you like those movies I mean it is
more of the same or the same you know
because I am excited about endgame which
is the part 2 to infinity war and it
ties into that as I understand it is
that correct again yeah it does
and into where you want a date when you
saw the movie last night
nope I was all alone in weeping by
yourself did you really go by yourself
to the movie theater yeah I wanted to
get a house oh that's really I think
that's a really cute wholesome thing to
do
yin is a is a big time saw the movie guy
that's a very confident play I I go like
once a week and it's hard to find people
who go that often oh and are you single
amp yeah ladies he's for someone to join
up to the movies every week hello Serena
yeah you watch a movie once a week yeah
pretty much
cuz there's not that many good movies
yeah you must see a lot of fun well
there's a lot of like indie type movies
that you can dig up why is the camera
meet we don't have a camera on and no
the others camera privileges taken away
oh man because it's just my dumb mug
every time I talk to anyone but yeah I
don't like that you gotta fix that we
need to add one cuz the when I was just
pointing at everyone you just didn't
really see anyone what can we do about
that we should think about how can we
get show that because if if Ian's
talking I'm sitting here like taking out
because I don't think the cameras on it
I'm like you know I need a break I need
that break from having the camera on me
maybe we'll work on a webcam yeah we can
I don't care yeah we can figure it out
let's webcam him alright
simple yeah okay in well thanks for the
update
appreciate it and thank you so much and
really God bless god bless ya bus so
where were we oh yeah salt Bay he's my
favorite so Bay is so unworthy of his
title of being a great chef and I'm
sorry to say that because some of the
stuff he does is just so stupid here's
one for example he cuts so this is the
full of gold flaked fillet that we've
just covered previously and so these
girls ordered it and what he does is he
puts it at the knife tip and he made
forces unto eat it now I've always
learned that you should never point a
knife at
let alone putting meat at the tip of a
sharp blade and making some I'd eat it
off it seems somewhat psycho thing to do
especially a customer guests like would
you do that to a guy yeah dude this is
kind of really strange I mean am I wrong
do I mean it's pretty strange right no
comment huh
I mean knifepoint in the face it's like
dude just serve them to me you're not
giving them a choice Punk I know it
tastes like [ __ ] - its right guys it's
seasoned with gold flakes how good can
that steak taste also you know what I
was thinking about sulphate does he wash
his elbows cuz think about like chefs
and if you've ever worked in a
restaurant your elbows get kind of dirty
because they're always leaning on [ __ ]
and services the guy's bouncing salt off
his elbows like dog do you wash your
elbows yeah I love it I love to eat a
fillet seasoned with squid the gold
flakes
gimme a break salt Bay yeah right and
finally guys before we go to break and
talk about all the good stuff so let me
break them yeah this is that what I
dubbed the salmonella burger I saw this
on Instagram yeah
was that your title food and cold out
wait what oh you can have it look at
that that's not that's straight-up raw
that is so raw inside mad cow disease
now take a look at this okay how about
the raw ground beef burger yeah
seriously literally not even cooked bro
what the half man you know when I was in
New York I noticed this phenomenon I saw
all the time at we went to delis all the
time and I would notice old people
eating burgers that were rare and they
will order them bloody rare yeah old
people that's what they're trying to die
they're trying to end it like a whole
day people would do it super rare I
thought the old people thing was to like
burn it to a crisp every single one was
like I want it super rare burger well a
lot of diners and stuff like that and
you know burger at a diner you don't
want it rare for sure we would see it a
lot I would order no pink at all I'm not
[ __ ] around but imagine being like 85
and having like diarrhea food poisoning
I mean that's a way to go that's enough
for that so up next we've got Papa John
has finally resolved with Papa John
don't go away to find out the stunning
details who may shock you our Kelly has
a meltdown you will be shocked and awed
by this and finally Michael Jackson did
he do it
find out after the break
admit it you think that cybercrime is
something that happens to other people
and you may think that nobody wants your
data or the hackers can't grab your
password or credit card details but you
are wrong
stealing data from unsuspecting people
on public Wi-Fi is one the simplest and
cheapest
that hackers make money when you leave
your internet connection unencrypted you
might as well be writing your password a
credit card number on a huge billboard
or on your freaking forehead because
it's that easy to get that's why I
decided to take action I protect myself
from cyber criminals using oak spruce VP
Express VPN secures and then analyzes
and then minimizes and then anonymizes
your internet browsing by encrypting
your data and hiding your public IP
address expressvpn it's easy to use apps
run seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone or tablet
turning on expressvpn protection only
takes one click and using expressvpn I
could safely serve a public Wi-Fi
without being snooped on or having my
data stolen for less than seven dollars
a month you can get the same expressvpn
that I use myself expressvpn is rated
number one VPN service by TechRadar it
comes with a 30-day money-back guarantee
so protect your online activity today
and find out how you can get three
months of free production at expressvpn
dot-com / h3 that's expr ESS VPN comm /
h3 for three months free with a one-year
package visit Express Express VPN
dot-com / h3 to learn more nobody really
has time to go to the post office you're
busy right ela who's got time for all
the traffic parking lugging all the mail
and packages it's a real hassle that's
right that's thank you that's why you
need stamps.com one of the most popular
time-saving tools for small businesses
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you time and money with
discounts that you couldn't even get at
the post office step Sarkar brings you
all the amazing services of the US
Postal Service right to your computer
whether your small office sending
invoices or an online sellers shipping
out products or even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day stamps.com
can handle it all with these simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send once your mails ready you hand it
to your mail carrier or drop it into
mailbox
it's that simple folks with stamps I'll
come you got five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off
Priority Mail what that's a huge
discount not to mention as a fraction of
the cost for those expensive postage
meters types of scan stamp it stamps
comm is a no-brainer saving you time and
money it's a no wonder that 700 thousand
small businesses already use stamps comm
so right now for our listeners you get a
special offer that includes four week
trial plus a free postage blots digital
scale what without any long-term
commitment so just go to stamps comm
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in h3 that's
stamps comm hit that microphone and type
in h3 let's all get shipping and
stamping right now
Papa John as you know he is a man that
has become a part of this nation this h3
army if you were and Papa John as you
know was ousted from his own company we
followed this story extensively now
there has been developments in the story
the fight between Papa John and Papa
John's which I'll never tire of saying
that seems to have finally been settled
as Papa has agreed to give up his seat
on the board in exchange for the ability
to have input in choosing his successor
Wow Papa John is still a largest
shareholder of the company so although
he's not no longer CEO he still wields
considerable influence it's so confusing
to me I don't understand how big
companies are how it works but I guess
I'm starting to understand so you have
the board and they're the ones who make
decisions on the actual yes company well
I think the but you have shareholders
and so shareholders don't have any
influence there's people that own stocks
but if you're on the board
and again I don't know what I'm talking
about yeah but I think more Directors
vote on certain issues and then there's
the CEO that manages the day-to-day
there like the chief officer okay so in
other words as as I don't know who wrote
this but it's act the right of the pizza
king to choose his pizza Prince shall
not be infringed and since the country
began a Shatner has was hesitant founded
about 35 years ago has completely
scrubbed yes you we know that here hit
me hit me with it she sued his own
company several times as part of this
deal he has agreed to drop two losses he
had brought against the company in a
statement on Tuesday mr. Shatner said
the agreement would help avoid a costly
and expensive proxy
proxy war by identifying a mutually
acceptable new pizza God in other words
I brought this pizza Empire and have
nothing and if though at a flower out of
water out of salt I beat the door with
my very hands bow this was meant to be
your pizza crust bowl you were meant to
sauce pepperoni to buy and now we must
choose together a pizza successor about
at home as Papa John how could you take
Papa Joe now to Papa John it don't make
no sense it's the company as a call to
Papa John I am Babu John you get to
break that sauce bubbling with life
now they say to me like I said
slideshows prefer John pictures they say
to me Papa
you must a set of the lawsuit so we
cannot deserve a with the lawsuit Papa a
Papa divided cannot stand and to this I
say Oh was better stand for the pizza
empire how you want or what the
chuck-e-cheese owed the Little Caesar
more like little seizure I am Papa John
I built Papa John's
from the ground up and remained its
largest shareholder I love my company
its employees especially what was the
name of that delivery boy who brought
the pizza well give a big dip
Matt Matt we love that big dip
franchisees and customers the board
wants just so this is my website and my
way to talk to you now you've seen my
home I have a pizza silence now if you
want to own the pizza game we must have
come to a geta I elect to be the next
pizza god
papa bow-bow
we should write a script about this
whole story for a movie now we are
talking now you're talking and I imagine
my axe has changed now I imagine Papa
John's yeah he's in his backyard
putting up the laundry and all that you
know and then suddenly a disaster
strikes a heart attack facedown in the
mud just like in God food who takes over
his trusty loyal son he didn't want to
be involved in that circumstances we
can't even include this in with the big
tip Matt and because his story
apparently oh yeah was trapped met with
tragedy tragic Matt the delivery boy had
apparently tragically passed away oh the
chat chat saying rip Matt to a no rip
Matt oh man tipped but not forgotten you
know I never felt the urge to make a
movie but um popping on the topic first
for John John Oh Papa versus pop like
there's a river screamer well there was
this great OJ Simpson
true-crime documentary-like oj versus
the people of the united states were
both people whatever yeah so Papa John
verse Papa John like the court case I
mean what is that yeah fantastic
welcome to Papa's house how what if the
Papa John Wooden worked for like little
seizures or something now Papa is forced
to go to the competing family hmm I
don't think any pizza place would take
then with these hands I've built the
pies I've made sauce you think that I'm
out on the street with the knowledge
what that son I have the money I've made
what are you about a gala GU about a go
and now you forced me to join another
family who have sworn allegiance against
I have sworn my sworn enemy so is he
like Italian in your head or yes he's
the Godfather what is he in reality he's
Italian from what Kentucky or some [ __ ]
yeah why but yes he's from Ohio or
something
he's an old-school white boy can I drop
the n-word and now I've been forced to
join with my sworn enemies I had made an
elite I said if I see an employee of
Little Caesars they are dead whatever
they walk in my neighborhood and how
[Music]
violent no no and now i'm delivering
pizzas for Little Caesars it's such a
shame I chop to the door without it's
localized of character I show up to the
door
delivering a little caesars beats and
they laugh at me they say I'll jump no
did I get better break them they don't
respect me my name is Papa John no it's
like they carry their front Lord over
the ring turned into Gollum cuz of you
eatin it up alright so our hearts go out
to Bubba
in other words Tom J and the chat
suggests Andy Serkis should play Papa
John in the film but as mocap like a CG
Papa John one if we get cast like Tim
Heidecker would be fantastic as Papa
John's or like just mix it up really I
just like the picture of him being the
only CG character like the older all
angel movie it's just a CG Papa John's
with a live action cast like Roger
Rabbit we couldn't get his permission so
we named it like Papa Papa Jan Jane all
right so our Kelly we've spoken about
our Kelly I find our Kelly to be first
of all very interesting foil to what's
going on with Michael Jackson because
people have no problem accepting the
reports the allegations the
documentaries about our Kelly everybody
takes that at face value you know
we've all kind of come together and said
you know what our Kelly is kind of F
dubbed it let's not supporting anymore
Michael Jackson is different the people
the the amount of defending and not just
well it's one thing to defend Michael
Jackson but there's there's an active
campaign it's this really vicious very
vicious people who do not like differing
opinions it's just it's a reminder to
like how huge Michael Jackson yeah and
people love him like yeah really nothing
else even comparable Yeah right
and although maybe the viewers maybe the
thing is it's like all the Beatles
squeezed into one person right that's
true right one super that's all head
he's a one-man show right and he's got
the story of being a victim and people
don't want to think that this person
could do horrible stuff I don't want to
for a long time I was like there's no
way yeah certainly me too I was always
on the fence with Michael Jackson but
before we get into that let's first talk
about our Kelly because he was in the
news he did it his first interview you
know being accused and people started
canceling his shows and taking him off
the radio there was a documentary about
it
this was the catalyst for all this again
an interesting foil to Michael Jackson
it was a great documentary was it called
leaving or know something about
surviving or surveyed yes surviving or
Kelly
it was fantastic documentary basically
alleging that he has a harem really of
girls living with him who here again
they're not being chained up but they're
being it's manipulated they're being
I mean brainwashed for lack of a better
word so it's not like the they can't go
walk out but there's it's abuse itself
certainly abuse there's no question
about it but at any rate I mean it's
hard to explain the whole you know what
but go ahead and watch this
but where he's defending himself would
it be for me with my crazy pass on what
I've been through oh right now I just
think I need to be a monster and hold
girls against they will chain them up in
my basement and and don't let them eat
and don't let them out unless they need
some shoes down the street from the
Onkel sounds like Eddie Murphy yeah he's
acting it sounds it's like Eddie Murphy
bed is that is that some detail in the
story that I'm unaware of about yeah
that's such a weird aside yeah and I
don't recall them ever saying he chained
anyone up either you know what I mean
like that's part of kind of it's like
well no what he does is he makes every
anecdote more extreme just be like oh I
never did that making a mockery oh yeah
making it so crazy so hyperbolic that
it's obviously yeah but people nobody
believes our Kelly so it's kind of the
sound guys like don't laugh he's got the
mic on his chest he keeps slamming the
sound guys like oh god I've seen people
even give this news channel [ __ ] for
giving him any airtime Wow oh sure let
the guy speak let's hear him out well
legendary yeah yes I mean if anything
he's so volatile yeah this said it just
goes to show that you know behind closed
doors is what I mean the guy's got a
temper clearly at this point we briefly
pause the interview to give Kelly a
moment this publicist helped calm him
down
his publicist that's his crisis manager
literally it's a crisis manager Provost
how can he afford a crisis manager when
he came and post bail
Kent he has no money apparently that
guy's working on um can't well they say
he claims that he has very little cash
but I'm sure he has like assets you know
he probably just have liquid cash but
stuff no you think it's all gone at this
point I've seen reports that he's dead
broke yeah I mean he he he well he just
went back to prison for for owning one
hundred and sixty thousand dollars in
back child support that he never paid
yeah so so some anonymous female friend
came and posted $100,000 bail for him to
get out and then two weeks later he went
back into prison for a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars on back child support
you never pay yeah really I think
doesn't have any money which is crazy
because at his peak success I read he
was worth 150 million
well imagine blowing that much money I
mean our Kelly was extraordinarily
popular in the 90s yes yes pretty much
top apparently the full interview is
gonna come out tonight at Nate we're
more than yeah I saw some clips they
were phenomenal yeah they're really
milking it I can't blame them it's
really it's huge I love how they're
dabbing his makeup as he's them having a
meltdown
this isn't that doesn't even make sense
why would I hold all these women his
publicist is like not making my job easy
to told me we're gonna like dude snap
out of it real but Kelly's emotions
remained raw it's real girls out there
missing it's real young girls out there
being abducted being raped okay when I
saw this when I saw this is like you got
any leads
you know but it's like that argument is
strange because it's like well you got
leads I mean Chinese they really do have
chains on their own
okay Robert we have to have a
conversation no I don't want you just
ranting at the camera lady I came here
for them to hear I need help
what kind of help this is the kind of
help I need yes what kind of help I need
somebody to help me not have a big heart
because that's like being at the job
interview being like well my biggest my
biggest defect is that I work too hard
I'm too good at everything you sound
like you're playing the victim here
you sound like our Kelly you do you're
playing the victim I'm just telling the
truth
and the reason I'm emo Robert apologized
for that no because this is the first
time I was able to say something have
said nothing you know you remained top
so what's awesome it's amazing how I
find him very good not convincing this
performance was well what's even less
convincing is when he brings out his two
girlfriends so yeah which was the
follow-up no yeah yeah I mean I guess
for me mostly I'm just I'm struck by by
how different the reaction are Kelly is
compared to Michael Jackson and you know
people people always joke Oh like have
you seen the Michael Jackson documentary
as somehow trying to Lampoon people who
were like oh I watched the documentary I
changed my mind and they act like oh
well you haven't done any research all
you've done is washing documentary but
the r.kelly one is actually has less
firsthand because the art Kelly one is
just from the parents perspective yeah
but the Michael Jackson one is
first-hand experiences and I actually
felt like in the Michael Jackson one
throughout with them telling their
stories you are always seeing evidence
corroborate the song Robert they're
saying like Michael would come to our
house every night and then there's
pictures over in their house he would
send us faxes every night and they had a
fax he would send it was one of the
weirdest thing yes
my god he used to send us letters used
to write us notes used to call him leave
messages they've got all of it
he gave us memorabilia he did this he
did that he got all of it they've got
pictures they got photos they got
everything to corroborate every detail
and I mean even public footage of
Michael with the family or Michael with
the kid like yeah it's all out there so
I felt like if anything that dog Michael
Jackson available had a lot more
everything I feel like it was absolutely
credible and people who are decrying the
documentary are protesting it and out of
protests are not watching it I find that
ironic because they're so obsessed with
research but this documentary even if
you are dead even if you totally
believed Michael Jackson is innocent
this is a documentary worth watching
because it's research it's first-hand
account of people who are who are
accusing him of the most heinous one of
the most heinous crimes you can imagine
so even if you're dead set on Michael
Jackson's innocent
these guys are fraud you gotta watch it
for the for research at least if I'm
having a discussion about a book that
you haven't read you can't really talk
to me about the book if I'm talking it's
like you haven't watched it how can you
have a conversation about it so I guess
they're thinking they're not watching it
out of product test because they
disagree with the concept of making a
one-sided documentary or not including
like the other side of Michael Jackson's
family and all just to be devil's
advocate and you know their argument is
that prior to it being released at least
on HBO you know screened a couple times
I think it's Sundance and everything you
know the the PR campaign already kicked
into full gear to discredit the guys so
before anybody before anybody even had
the opportunity to watch it they had
been convinced that there's no reason to
because these guys you know don't have
any credibility why why should I listen
to them well and a lot of this stuff I
hear people saying is stuff like oh they
already testified under oath and now
they change their mind because they're
getting paid from HBO and somebody who
says that is somebody who clearly hasn't
watched a documentary because that's one
of the main thrusts of the documentary
is exploring how can you testify under
oath several times for Michael Jackson
and then
all the sudden come out so hard against
him and it's it's way bigger they
weren't paid by HP oh by the way sorry
they weren't paid by anyone yeah but
that that point is exactly why this
documentary is bigger than just Michael
Jackson and that's what Oprah was saying
in the third part because it's about
abuse and you can you can go on your
whole life not knowing even that what
happened to you as a kid was wrong and
then at some point as an adult all of a
sudden understand what happened and like
I think it's just people don't
understand abuse right and so they're
like oh they changed their story and
they stood for him before but I think
they really showed that part so well in
the documentary and that was why I found
it so like good yeah well we will talk
more about that because we are working
our way down to that I wanted to say
about that so let's watch the girls
interviewed on our Kelly this is a first
time here bring to be honest with you
that your parents are trying to get
money from our Kelly okay because your
father told a very different story
yeah to me last night yeah he's he's the
manipulator
he's very manipulative so he's the one
you need to watch out for but uh my dad
and my mom
they're studies to send threats to both
me and him they said oh I'll call your
Nick attaches all over the world I'm
going to ruin you I'm going to ruin him
if he doesn't send twenty thousand
dollars to this bank account by Monday
I'm gonna put everything out there and
then ten thousand dollars after that you
trying to solicit me like I'm some hole
I'm not I'm your child
exactly yeah you sound very angry with
your parents you sound very angry and
very pained it's very insightful at
first you pick the upset while you're
crying tell me right
I was like what money the guy can't even
get post bail what's cool this is the
worst shakedown ever
that's the worst claim that their
parents just want their kids back like
they haven't seen these girls in years
now they can't talk to them they're the
last thing they want is money and their
claim is is that they're the parents
have naked pictures of them together and
that they're threatening to release how
would the parents have that is the first
time anyone said there's no background
to the parents asking for money or all
that stuff mmm well yes she's and then
she goes on to say well I'll just play
in Ezreal this is more than gossip this
is more than just rumors these are
decades of allegations she spent that
fits over there decades we're here to
talk about what our parents are doing
right now right and what they're doing
right now is off for money right now
both sets of parents deny ever asking
Kelly for money or receiving money from
him by the way she was saying earlier
before this time stamp that it was her
parents idea for her to go become a
singer for our Kelly I mean they were
like you need to go be with our Kelly
and send us money yeah even the most
while evil people wouldn't dream
something like that up you know it's
just not plausible done whatever here
you know this is a great detail that as
I was talking to them because I had
talked to the father there are two very
different stories I'm sure mr. Clary if
he watches this this morning his head
will explode because he has a very
different version of what these young
women are saying and his team had told
us that our Kelly would not be in the
room after the interview started he was
around the corner behind them they
couldn't see him but it points at points
during the conversation he would call
very loudly like that so they were aware
that he was there how wild is that
three yeah that's a damn that's a really
crazy detail
daddy's listening training them up in my
basement yeah he didn't do that
Zack remember he didn't do that
Oh crazy and furthermore Your Honor
ladies and gentlemen of the court I
leave you with all the evidence I got it
you need do you have girl would you like
to come back did you
I love her clerk order and so now
romantic baby girl did you get your
shots because I don't want malaria
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so good ever this is not a joke girl
meet Megan back hit me with that music
ooh this is not a joke
oh girl did you get your shots shots
girl do you have your papers paper this
is not a joke please meet me and back
and back girl we going to America I
think got no chains but I got 9 games to
lock you up and you're gonna call me
daddy daddy hmm
I said girl do you have your shots
do you have STD reports America mm yeah
so if you're really pretty I'll accept
gonorrhea chlamydia is okay but
nothing's curable can stay if you've
gotten hit by hepatitis or HIV I'm gonna
have to skip you and I'm going overseas
but if you've got your paper and your
passports you can come with me my name
is Robert and you can live in my reap
engine call me daddy you can get some
shoes but don't get a sandwich the Jews
run Hollywood
yeah did you get your shots do you have
your pant but this is not a joke I love
this clutch
my uncle
[Music]
but you know how many girls are nod if
they're like uh he's talking to me
making a proposition don't fake these
goats ever ever ever do you have your
shots I mean open you here Rob it's like
so personal this is what we call
grooming yes which we'll learn more
about in our next story
we're Rob to American Girl do you have
HIV then you can't come with me if you
have HIV then I don't want you my BP
inside of you bum Aditya is curable if
you're at ten if you're a seven then
I'll skip it you up chlamydia if your
innate I'll think about it
[Music]
how do you even think about that do you
have your shots fantastic it's so once
coming from the heart his heart's too
big and this is so real yeah the thing
is so like when you come from a place
like Ethiopia or even Israel you have to
get immunizations oh yeah this comes
from a very technical place the guy
knows what he's talking about he's been
through it a couple of times yes trying
to bring girls back precisely oh do you
have your passports have you shaved your
butthole to America yo girl come with
Robert
if you've shaved your butthole give me
pictures and back or let me inspect it
give me if did you bring your
immunization report okay great
do you have a valid passport okay great
now do you have your STD report looks
good background check you'll ride coach
and I'll ride first-class go went back
to America I've got an extra room in my
mansion welcome to my harem did I
mention that I have ten other
girlfriends when I make a dress up like
a boy that's true in a documentary
there's one I may dress up like a boy we
work yeah that's true wait you haven't
seen it that happy did not tell anyone
yes yes and frankly I'm not gonna watch
it because I know he's innocent I know
he's a saint it's a protest listen he
was a he was on trial and he was
acquitted our Kelly was acquitted in a
trial that means he's innocent and do
you have your shops and your documents
jama'a
Michael Jackson's coming up trigger
warning for everybody who's too
sensitive yes Michael Jackson I'm not
saying he did it but
let's be honest with our folks Michael
Jackson slept in a bed with the young
kids every night without parents
presents just use your brain people use
your brain who does that I didn't have a
childhood
that's ignorant I love to think about it
if it wasn't Michael Jackson saying yes
music oh yeah yeah you know what is the
little kids say and Michael Jackson's
room at night just as an exercise to
think about the stuff Michael Jackson
did but if it was just a random guy like
your neighbor so gross
but he didn't have a childhood you did
you factor that dissipation yes that
that kind of even makes it more likely
more likely that it would be [ __ ] up
right mm-hmm absolutely so here this is
what I'll say okay we're entering the
Michael Jackson yeah that's basically
and Jeckle yeah yeah so for those of you
that cannot handle it who are in
protests who will be triggered or
otherwise offended by this I hope that
you keep watching actually because I do
enjoy a good amount of viewership on my
episodes flow so I encourage you to keep
watching but listen also closely because
I think that I have in some compelling
arguments to make to you and I'm not one
again if you're if you're someone that
thinks that the documentary is BS and
anyone who believes that Michael Jackson
did these crimes is like a Looney tune
like listen to me and I I don't blame
you for thinking that way because and
the documentary explores this concept so
good because the documentary is about is
the best I've seen about the Sun and not
about Michael Jackson not about the
survivors but about abuse and how it
happens about the grooming products or
the grooming process and what was so
magnificent about Michael Jackson as
we've said there's never been a pop star
like him ever he was like the Beatles
squeezed all into one person comes oh I
enjoyed being a victim and just loved by
the whole work like seriously everywhere
so he in a sense had this hat or one of
the victims said we were already grooms
when we met him right because he is this
God on this planet earth and he in a in
a way he has groomed the world and I'm
gonna talk about that if you think I'm
crazy and you think I'm [ __ ] that's
fine you can hate me just at least
listen wonders let's introduce what
we're talking about yeah the HBO
documentary that came out leaving
Neverland leaving Neverland if you're
wondering where to watch it it's on HBO
HBO which I think is a little bit
unfortunate because not everyone has HBO
I think a lot more people would watch it
hey either you had the hook-up though if
you got Amazon Prime you can get a free
week trial that's all yeah and it's
immediate you just pop it open eyes you
know it's funny everybody watch Game of
Thrones but somehow when it comes to
something there's anything else nobody
has HBO hilarious okay I just wanted to
give the details for anyone who's not
caught up you're done I'm done passing
the it's it's a two-parter yeah and then
there's a third part following up it's
an interview that Oprah Winfrey
interviews the two victims and the
director of the documentary yes I I
thought all three were so good mm-hmm
so there's another documentary that was
that I watched on Netflix called
abducted in plain sight yes and and you
know I had watched that recently and
it's about a man who befriended a family
and gradually built up this relationship
with this young girl he had fallen in
love with but he had groomed the family
he had groomed the child to the point
over a long period of time that he was
able to just take the girl and run off
like there was no checks and balances
and the way that it happened
was so similar it was so and it was so
similar to what I heard in this
documentary and again that's what I
thought was so important and compelling
it's about as a whole child abuse and
about the grooming process so bad you
know I feel like I was in crazy world
seeing all this like when I first saw
this documentary I was so outraged I
mean I was like my goodness this is
absolutely insane and I go online to
read the conversation about it and it's
not only do I see first of all not a lot
of people talking about it but those
that are talking about it are brutally
brutally brutally viciously attacking
anyone who's speaking in support of the
documentary and just decrying the the
two dudes the two victims the host Oprah
anyone just absolutely decrying them and
I've thought like man I'm in crazy world
but I quickly realized that all the
people who were doing that haven't
watched the documentary it's so plainly
obvious because a lot of their talking
points are things that are addressed
widely in the documentary but I was just
surprised bike that he had so much sway
and pull people cared so deeply about
him still to this day so it is a
testament first it almost is a testament
to the fact that the world has been
groomed because now even ten years after
his death and long after he had an
active career I think she goes to show
that even now the he has this army of
people that can see no wrong in him
going to war war with these people so it
kind of proves the point that he has
this like mystical attraction this
mystical pull now I was always on the
fence about Michael Jackson me too you
know I really didn't want to believe it
it's like what the [ __ ] Oh Jackson and
I'm a huge fan of his music as I'm sure
most of us are I mean the guy's a
phenomenal talent I mean the guy's like
he's a he's a whenever the one a one in
a thousand year talent we would put out
videos of him dancing and just like
stare at it like this is perfection I
mean he had it all he was incredible
singer he was an incredible dancer the
guy invented like pop dance for Christ's
sake I mean he really did he
credible songwriter that guy was
phenomenal and I was always on the fence
but you know I have a thought experiment
that I would always pose to myself that
always you know edged me towards he did
it and that thought experiment is very
simple imagine a man any man sleeping in
bed with a young child a young boy every
night for 30 days straight with no
parent what are the chances I asked you
what are the percent chances that he
didn't touch that little boy in an
appropriate way and I would think hard
on that and I would say you know I have
to say in all honesty using my brain in
my common sense forgetting about all the
mysticism everything it's zero it's zero
percent that is just not something that
you do okay so again this is just the
beginning of the rabbit hole I've got a
lot of things to share so that was a
thought experiment always kind of
pushing me towards you know what I think
he probably did do it and that was an
idea that came from him like it's not
like the kid said oh I want to sleep
with you he would tell the kid yeah you
should come sleep with me mm-hmm he put
that idea out well here actually since
we're I'm gonna skip the head because I
have a really compelling video that
support that literally some shows
Michaels saying that and here what I
what I like to talk about here is
undeniable undisputed facts okay I'm not
gonna toss about conjecture I'm not
gonna make assumptions I'm not gonna say
stuff that hasn't proven I'm just gonna
show you an undisputed fact here's a
video of Michael with one of the his his
childhood friends okay like no no no no
and then he finally said okay if you
love me to see what a day so here you
can hear the kid saying I didn't want to
sleep on the bed oh man
Michael Jackson here is shown
manipulating this kid and saying right
if you love me exactly pressuring him if
you love me the god that you look up to
you'll sleep in my
and this is the beginning of the
grooming process that's like so step 1
and you get him to sleep in his bed and
then the next night it's obvious it's
gonna sleep all that yeah exactly and
then they both sleep in the bed for 30
nights
now here if you skip to the end it is
there's a fascinating another detail
I'll sleep on them but haven't you got a
spare room or a spare house here where
he could have stayed no yes we have
guest units but whenever kids come here
they always want to stay with me really
never because literally that was
disputed in the first second of this
book five seconds so Michael is saying
oh well that guy the kids live with me
because they always want to so what
happens he puts this thought in the kid
and then the kid goes to his mom and
like mom can I sleep with Michael right
so it seems like the kid wanted it but
it starts from and one of the hallmarks
of child abuse is convincing the kid
that they want it and that they like it
that's why victims of child abuse carry
so much guilt and remorse because
they're so completely and shamed because
in their mind on it they're so
conflicted because when they think back
they remember enjoying it they remember
wanting it they remember that it was fun
and exciting and so it's hard to
reconcile as a grown person those
feelings that you know you had when you
were a kid because those feelings last
right and when you think back as
yourself as a little five-year-old you
as a 20 year old you sometimes would
play it in your 20 old brain and that
five year old kid it's hard to make
sense of how you felt then so this is
what Michaels doing to this kid he's
going he on one hand the kid kind of
ratted him out and said hmm Michael said
if you love me you'll stay in my bed and
then a mere two minutes later Michael
saying oh well kids only sleep in my bed
and I don't always learn them because
they want to mm-hmm
again so and I have never invited them
in my room really they always just want
us to what about if you love me asleep
in my bed I stay with you tonight I go
if it's okay with your parents yes you
can't do your parents
that you were here so that's all I mean
guys that's a lot that's kind of a lie
right we can all I think agree on that I
know they're happy cuz I was happy do
you think come with you your muster time
with I wasn't really move Affairs I was
with you Michael most of the time but
they were happy that you were here yeah
no now what they were happy they got to
hang out at the ranch and get wined and
dined yeah wait there was something
whenever you guys almost come one more
thing here from this clip funny yeah
watch this this part here very
unsettling people here that children
from other families have come and
they've stayed in your house look at
them holding hands stayed in your
bedroom okay and look how his head is on
his shoulders
I mean what the that's not how you act
with a friend let's say Michael is has
the mentality of a little boy in a red a
child honey so that that's why he likes
hanging out with friends what the how do
you explain this
even as a young boy I would never do
that with a grown man or for our way to
another younger boy I wouldn't do that
with anyone it's just like as a young
kid I would be horrified to do that with
anyone yeah even my whatever anyone a
girl friend a boy my mom my dad my
brother I wouldn't do that to anybody
right but here he is doing it in plain
sight and that's what I mean by Michael
Jackson groomed the world because he
convinced everybody that he was just a
young boy himself and that's why he
loved and he was blameless and he's
holding hands with kids they're cuddling
with him on camera and you would always
say on camera like I just love kids you
know this everything you know about him
is things that he would put out there
basically yeah that is he's been a
victim himself and he loves kids and
kids are like it's his guiding kids you
would say all this stuff that see God
see I just want to help case think about
that and so you've your whole life
you're you're absorbing this without
even realizing right so when someone
comes and tells you the opposite about
him you already have like sorry
yeah or away or as a parent when you
bring
your kids over to come hang out with
them and Michael's like well we're gonna
just sleep in my bedroom at night okay
they're having a sleepover and then it's
important to mention and what they show
in the documentary when the parents come
with the kid he shows the parents a good
time too
oh he grew and it's like the bedtime
it's like a dream for the parent to you
meet him Michael Jackson and he loves
you and he talks to you and he calls you
and gives you gifts right and he bought
one of them a house he bought one he
just paid just straight-up paid them and
one of the things that is an
undisputable about this documentary if
you watch it is how he groomed not only
the kids but the parents here one of
these main kids
Wade Robinson Wade now weight is super
interesting because he was with Michael
Jackson and I say with because they were
in a relationship for seven years now he
would call and talk to the mom every day
and this is corroborated because he sent
faxes to the family he sent video
messages to the family he sent drawings
he sent letters he did left messages
they have all of this evidence of him
talking best friends connecting so
powerfully with the mom he would call
talk to mom he would call and talk to
the kid and wait is the guy that people
keep bringing up is so uncredible
because he testified I get weird like he
testified that nothing happened with
Michael twice but his story was so crazy
and they explained it so detailed in the
documentary like Wade was one of these
star kids that was so good at imitating
the Michael Jackson dance moves and he
was a super fan of Michael he was
actually somewhat famous as a kid
because his dancing was so phenomenal
and so Michael Jackson like look how we
got to contests and with adults and they
met him when he was seven and the abuse
started when he was seven yeah and and
so these guys the both of these guys in
the video they both had sons and they
both started having mental breakdowns
they when their Sun started to reach the
age that they were when the abuse
started and because they were able to
actually see what they were like at that
age because that when they saw their
beautiful innocent pure son at seven who
they know full well is incapable of
entering a romantic relationship of any
kind or having sexual relations with
somebody you know what I mean and you
could see how easily manipulated and
malleable they are so I think well what
they both say is they both had sons
around there like about to reach that
age you know a few years before maybe
but and so they could finally connect
with that younger themselves and
understand where they were mentally and
that's when they started to understand
that they were truly abused and a lot of
and both of them were having like
extraordinary mental issues yeah
impression and anxiety and self-loathing
that they didn't understand and so and
and they never told anyone about their
abuse because Michael according to their
account from the very beginning first of
all they had this intense passionate
love and Michael would always say to
them repeat to them if we if you ever
tell anyone about this where we ever get
caught I'm gonna go to jail for life I'm
gonna be over ever my whole career is
come over and you're gonna go to jail
for life and so they're like he was like
this is our secret this is our love we
love each other and if anyone ever finds
out I will be I will go to jail and you
will go to jail and he kept repeating
that to them throughout the whole
duration of the relationship and that's
you hearing this when you're seven and
like and which is so important the most
famous magical person that's lived in
recent history so for them they were
both fully convinced until they had like
sons and started having mental breakdown
that they were gonna take this to the
grave
yes also they didn't really know for a
long time that what happened was wrong
right which is like because kids are run
over the problem with child abuse
something I've learned from therapy is
that we all take things for granted that
are we take
normal things for granted that we think
are normal until you meet other people
or talk to other people and until you
can compare your your experience to them
you don't then you can all of a sudden
realize oh that was not normal at all
right yeah and so that's very much what
happened with these guys they had an
experience that was so unusual that was
so powerful that was so transformative
by someone who was so powerful and so
magical they didn't have the context
didn't have the comparison to they
didn't have the tools and I mean got my
god it's unimaginable and you've seen by
the way the visceral and the hate that
accusers of Michael Jackson received and
the disbelief that they always get so
all of these things combined and also
they never stopped loving Michael
Jackson that's what you learn in the
documentary too they still love him
right
because there's still so many emotions
for them they still like right they
don't know how to break it down still
one of the compelling things for me too
was like so as they aged they kind of
grew out of favor with him and in favor
of other young boys and they would see
him with other young boys kind of with
the same body language and they felt
like rejected like they were no longer
the favorite because I mean they were in
love
they weren't literally in love right and
so they felt rejected and slowly over
time as they aged they grew apart from
him they would see him occasionally and
talk to him occasion they were still
friendly but they grew apart and I and a
lot of them they said that they were
going to trial to testify on Michael's
behalf and all the parents and the whole
family did it because they were they
were Michael's soldiers they were going
to war for Michael there were winning
his favor back they thought you know I
just want Michael to love me again and
I'll do anything to please him to defend
him they were his warriors in this
battle and so even though one hand they
knew that that had happened to them that
was a secret love that they shared
and they loved Michael dearly and they
wanted that love back and so they went
to war with him again this is all
corroborated it's very compelling it's
very it's just it's a fascinating look
at child abuse and grooming and it's so
so so compelling and I have other things
I want to talk about here now that's a
little bit of an overview of the
documentary now here's something
interesting to happen yesterday Corey
Feldman
who was one of Michael Jackson's staunch
worth staunch worthy supporters who
himself was just on staunch thank you
Dan because he himself was a victim of
child abuse and so a lot of his fans and
supporters have been looking to Corey
Feldman as evidence that Michael Jackson
did nothing well yesterday night after
Corey watched the documentary surprise
surprise Corey Feldman came out and did
an interview and said he can no longer
defend Michael Jackson after horrendous
abuse allegations Corey Feldman is
dramatically pulling back his support
for embattled friend Michael Jackson in
light of the horrendous child sexual
abuse allegations he said after watching
and processing leaving Neverland he he
said he could no longer support him so
again people keep thinking a kind of a
meme out of like oh you watch the
documentary you think you know
everything okay so let's go down the
line Corey Feldman best friend Michael
Jackson victim of abuse
he watched the documentary he found
something compelling in it also the fact
that that didn't happen with Corey
Feldman doesn't mean that Michael Guerin
abuse right right that's the big one him
and him in Macaulay Culkin yeah have
both always said nothing happened
between them which fair enough
and do it to everybody so again Michael
Jackson was a very cunning predator and
as many child predators are they are
very selective about who they choose
Michael Jackson has shown throughout the
documentary was very particularly he
found weak fan
he found families with weak bonds who
are easy manipulated parents who wanted
the limelight who wanted the money who
wanted to be associated with someone
like Michael Jackson and he would prey
on these families and use them against
each other I mean it's not every mom who
will leave their child with Michael
Jackson alone for 30 days I mean that
guy Wade Robson he was in Australia and
Michael would called them to their house
every day and he would talk to the mom
too
for a long time and eventually he got
her to move here with Wade and the
sister and basically this whole family
broke up over this whole drawing
absolutely destroy the family the dad
was left back they all abandon him and
he later committed suicide which was
that I mean the story of the dad was
absolutely reject the guy was totally
blameless I mean and they left her
brother there in Australia - yeah and so
actually now later on you see that this
family is so fractured today that the
child says that he has no feelings for
his mom that he can't forgive her what
for what she did is trying but you see
the pain and this family is a hundred
percent real it is broke that that is
dead you see the whole family in the
documentary they all give their
perspective oh yeah Michael called us
every night for two hours Michael was
sending us faxes every day here's the
fax
I mean disabling knew that he was
calling they would talk to him too so
yeah it's all there it's yet a little
sister who would go there to Neverland
who moved to California with them guess
who he didn't have sleeping in his room
every night
the little girl never loaded their whole
family knew that it was about Wade just
the boy which was interesting yes he was
obsessed with Wade
so again just because the popular
misconception is just because someone
wasn't abused doesn't mean that others
weren't he was very particular and he's
very smart
about who he did it with he did it with
people he could get away with and
Families he could manipulate and groom
and moms at parents who were like who
could put themselves in a state of
denial and exchange photos of all the
great things he
in the house mm-hmm okay so this by the
way I have to wash this several times a
day just to take take myself out of
crazy world this is the best thing I've
ever seen this guy Kyle Dunnigan follow
him on Instagram and Twitter he's the
funniest mother effort and the whole
freaking world and I just I'm so
thankful this video exists because when
I feel I'm I just put this on and I'm
like I think God there's people out
there that are still saying I like this
horrible HBO documentary about me it's
filled with lies and ignorance I would
never hurt children I love sleeping with
little boys that's all just a grown man
sleeping that is of course I [ __ ] them
kids come on
it's so obvious I was a good pedophile
too huh I felt a whole amusement park
and candy store and I say your kids like
candy maybe like yeah yeah we like yeah
but yeah you like it yeah okay yeah well
tell you about me the [ __ ] did did y'all
notice how I slip with little cute boys
not little girl that is so lovely she
was just cute little brother [ __ ]
tight ass mmm boys well better get back
to heaven I got in because I apologize
right before I died damn the rules if
you guys ever feel like going crazy
world with this video on Kyle Dunnigan
is just a genius but again he actually
makes some really fantastic points guys
he never slept with all of the boys he
befriended were like really handsome
models one was a TV commercial one was a
dad like these were really handsome
beautiful young boys right not fat boys
not ugly boys not little girls
it's very fricking true why explain that
the other time if he why why why do you
have a type exactly
I love how he goes of course I [ __ ] them
kids it's so obvious it is it's so
obvious I feel like
what did the little what did it uh
Michael Jackson say to little kids in
the middle of the night in his bedroom
the crazy thing is do I just got to say
it's like even if you accept nothing
happen which obviously is far-fetched
but nothing sexual happened but things
that are overt the things we know about
those are abuse like you know having a
seven-year-old sleep in your bed with
them 30 days in a row right like that
even if nothing sexual happened that's
Arielle abusing that kid yes so we were
spies
yeah not the kids not in school he's not
doing anything he's just spending time
with Michael Jackson yeah soon lives are
who they just play video games all day
that's cool I mean if you really cared
about a kid you would be like dude go to
school and come hang out with me on the
weekends
no here Michael wanted the kid to
immediately move in for a year yes the
mum to live the kid would imputed fact
by the way now what I want to go into
right now are undisputed facts about
Michael Jackson these are facts that
whether you support Michael Jackson or
not these are facts that we all can
agree are undisputed
so here's number one these are all facts
okay this is not conjecture this is
facts the hallway leading to Jackson's
bedroom was a serious security zone
covered by video and wired for sound so
that the steps of anyone approaching
would make dingdong sounds now this was
well done invented by the police and it
was covered a lot extensively in the
documentary as well is that he had like
several doors leading into his bedroom
they were all wired for sounds had video
cameras had bells so okay so now we so
now we have a place in time we have
Michael Jackson sleeping in bed with a
young boy in his bed for 30 days
straight and now let's add this element
of that
there's three doorways between and it's
a serious security zone with video and
wired for sound so that anyone
approaching makes a dingdong so let's
add that to the mix are you still let me
do a thought experiment with yourself
anybody else
yeah you know I mean I'm serious
so let's continue with undisputed facts
so far five boys Michael Jackson has
shared a bed with have accused him of
abuse Jordie Chandler
Jason Frant Francia Gavin Arvizo Wade
Robinson and Jimmy safe Chuck that's
five separate abuse allegations Jackson
paid 25 million dollars to settle the
Chandler lawsuit with 18 million going
to Jordie 2.5 million going to each of
the parents and the rest to the lawyers
Jackson said he paid that sum to avoid
something long and drawn-out
Francie also received 2.4 million from
Jackson now a lot of the defenders of
Michael Jackson point to this as proof
that these people are just after my
after money and so that supports the
fact that that they're liars but you
know that's what Kelly says - right well
it was just one money it's such a easy
way to dismiss yeah it's the easiest way
to say but what remedy first okay first
of all this is such a genius play by
Michaels lawyers and for the whole
propaganda machine because first of all
Michael Jackson could never risk being
found guilty mm-hmm I mean any amount if
there if there's a pot if there's a
possibility you could be found guilty
there's just no there's no chance so
paying them off first of all removes
that risk and it gives them the ability
to just characterize anybody as only in
for for the money so in well false one
fell swoop they are able to discredit
the the plaintiffs as money hungry and
to protecting his reputation by saying
oh well we were never found guilty we
settled out of court because we just
wanted them to go away all right but you
don't really pay 25 million
when you're not guilty I wouldn't I mean
as I'm not Michael Jackson though but I
mean I guess it makes sense I could see
that he's like you know what and he
would I read that he was on tour at the
time and his tours are worth like
hundreds of millions of dollars so they
were you know it's like he just went he
didn't want to deal with they he didn't
wanna jeopardize his tour mm-hmm make it
go away
and this you're talking about the 93
case right yes the original first one
the one that he did that was settled for
25 right it has an interesting detail
about it do you know who his lawyer was
in that case no Cochran right Hani
Cochran yes the guy who represented the
other man who was acquitted of crimes do
we all agree that OJ Simpson is guilty I
love how everyone points to the justice
system as the end-all be-all
yeah okay see really was acquitted well
the fundamental misunderstanding when
when you're acquitted it doesn't mean
you're innocent that's why they call it
not guilty it can't prove beyond a
reasonable doubt
to the jury that this person I built it
but it does not being convicted doesn't
mean it didn't happen they're not
magical they don't know they just can't
fully prove it in court a lot and also
abuse is one of the hardest things to
prove because she said right because at
the end of the day it's Michael and a
child in a room of themselves unless you
have pictures or videos or something
extraordinary I would do it really no
way to prove that it happened first of
all there were no it's not like today
when every kid has a cell phone
smartphone yeah today but even not even
today I don't know that every
seven-year-old could access evidence if
something had concern it's
extraordinarily difficult to to prove so
yeah exact the documentary is one side
that it's like yeah that's kinda like
the only option well in that argument
that for me doesn't make any sense
because and also what would it help if
what the Oscar and Michael's family was
I think we already know what they say
he's not guilty but but ultimately again
they were not in the bed we all agree
that he slept in the bed with them right
so right who was who was in the
room the kid the only one Michael
Jackson's passed away if anyone was
closest to them was the parents like
sleeping next door in a room movie and
the parents are in the movie and by the
way agreeing on all the details I mean
and the parents are basically forced to
admit that they're the worst people on
the whole planet yeah and they're like
almost the real villains of all these
mothers they have more to gain by lying
about it and saying like oh he's my
son's not telling the truth right yeah I
was open-minded to give the parents a
chance as far as starting the
documentary but like the longer it went
on just how could you just let all this
happen and be there and just let it
happen honey mommy I see them a lot of
them were just like kind of at a midlife
crisis satisfied with their life and
they saw their an opportunity for an
adventure of their boring mundane life
and both of them kept calling it's a
it's a like a fairy tale
yeah like a fairy tale yeah it's
charming came they were my feet they
were perfectly susceptible to his charms
you know and he knew that he absolutely
knew that you know the kids that that
guy who sued him or no he so Chandler
wasn't in the in the document it was the
one guy that sued him that it was
dismissed Wade Wade
so people so Oprah asked him well why
did you sue him you know like like well
how isn't it isn't that proof that it's
about money and he says well it's the
only way I could get them to listen to
me I felt like there was this great
injustice I wasn't thinking about my I
wanted to put it in front of a core and
I wanted people to have to listen to me
and to what happened to me what I have
to say also using the same platform that
he used before to defend my soul
powerful this guy went on trial twice
defending Michael mm-hmm when he was
brainwashed and he didn't understand the
whole picture he didn't understand he's
been abused
and he was the superfan of Michael and
he couldn't imagine Michael going to
prison he was like I gotta save him I
mean you gotta hear him explain it
obviously I'm doing it justice but no
you're doing good to him once he had
this breakdown an understanding of what
happened to him and he wanted to you
wanted to correct the record it kind of
makes sense that he would want to do it
again in front of court and have the
world hear it too so that he's not he
doesn't have to live with that guilt
yeah game he wants to redo it that that
actually that point was struck a chord
on me because it's so it makes so much
sense I want to get back on the stand
and tell the truth this time I just keep
saying people always saying it's just
soon so so you know like they can't
trust him because he changed his story
basically they just can't find him
trustworthy but it's just you gotta
understand child abuse well that's why
to those people I always say you shall
watch the documentary nest of it is
explaining how that's possible
yeah and if they were if it was just one
person
you know I'd maybe be a little bit more
sympathetic to that attitude that you
know maybe they're just trying this is a
scam or whatever but I mean these
allegations been around forever
yes it was he was never put in jail for
it but eventually you know when I think
it's five people have come out mm-hmm
saying that this happened to them and
there's five in total um you know when
there's that much smoke there's usually
fire especially when there's tons of
footage of the guy being a creep with
children like well let's watch that the
volume doesn't even matter
you just look just I mean come on we're
look we're looking at just use your
brain but also with the way the response
they're getting from the whole word
discourage it's really discouraging out
of people to come out how that that's
why I kind of entered the fray to begin
with is because I had made a tweet
saying that you know I Michael Jackson
is a child predator and I wanted I I
didn't see anyone voicing support for
these victims that I saw as dudes whose
life was and family was torn apart by
this heinous crime and now hated by the
world and I was at I was expecting to
see more support for them and I just I
felt so awful I felt like I wanted to
voice public support for for the film
and for these guys and that's why I
entered the fray on social media
now also something there's a another
misconception the guy who sued Michael
Jackson the case was thrown out people
show that as evidence that Michael
Jackson is innocence the truth is that
the case was thrown out not on its
merits but on the statute of limitation
it was a it was a technicality the court
said Michael Jackson passed on we can't
hold his estate his business liable for
this crime and so they threw it out on
on technicality making no judgment of
the merits of his claims okay because
it's like if you're saying child abuse
happen and it is cool you're gonna sue
the school right we're like yes he's not
part of it a company is not yeah it's
like Walt Disney abused me so I'm suing
Disney yeah well he said he it's a
different whatever and the first trial
yeah guys we you have to remember that
settling is not doesn't mean you're okay
we've talked enough the other big one
that you see constantly posted is the
thing about the FBI right yeah it was
investigated for ten years yes like
that's the go-to that I keep seeing over
and over and over again which you know
on a surface down all the pedaling let
me pull up the no but but go on then cuz
you know you've research this week yeah
so I mean with a lot of these claims you
know you you see there's all these memes
that get reposted over and over again
that have like kind of bullet points of
like this is why it's [ __ ] this is
why these guys are incredible and on its
surface it's like oh wow yeah I mean
that sounds that sounds fishy but almost
every single one of them if you dig into
it it's like so weirdly deceptive what
they're saying and yeah the the go-to is
well he was investigated by the FBI for
tires there
and they never found anything not a
single thing which like first of all
they were only the FBI was only involved
in so far as providing technical support
to local law enforcement so we're not
talking about like tapping his phone
lines 24-hour monitoring by the FBI kind
of thing we're talking about local law
enforcement sending magazines and tapes
to the FBI for analysis you know what I
mean like and this wasn't happening
continuously this was happening
once in the early 90s with the first
suit and again in the mid-2000s for the
second suit so it's over the course of
ten years but that's very different than
ten years continuously you know what I
mean like it's two instances of being
looked into and so that's not really you
know that's not really being fully
honest by saying he was being monitored
by the FBI for ten years yeah so this is
like the copypasta that you see all over
social media first of all I was honored
to be a guest on Tim's office hours
podcast and he made the most hilarious
observation about this which is so true
I wish I thought of it grandpa Simpson
is the raving delusional lunatic of the
show why is he the one whole thing it's
more it's almost like this was used
ironically actually yeah that's a very
funny point and the funny thing is that
these guys are saying oh we did our
reason didn't know but you didn't
whenever someone speaks they watch that
you didn't do your research all you did
was watch a documentary and now you're
an expert but these people are just
sharing a meme of grandpa Simpson who's
the crazy delusional character in the
show holding up a sign it says Michael
Jackson was monitored by the FBI for 13
years or his house was searched two
times by more than 70 officers not true
I mean highly exaggerated why doesn't
monitor it for 13 that's that's flat-out
false hundreds of kids were interviewed
somewhere offered money I don't know
what that's a very vague claim
I tried to investigate that I tried to
investigate every single thing on this
and some of it is so outlandish somes
like I don't even know how to find out
about this so nothing was found I mean
that's just flat-out yeah I mean
somebody says some suspect stuff was
definitely found well enough as you said
to bring it to criminal court and right
I mean they did prosecute him it's not
like there was no evidence again it's
not like logistics justice system is
perfect like soon so why not we all yeah
exactly
oh and it's not we all just we don't we
don't convict we convict people when
it's beyond a reasonable doubt okay so
it's entirely possible that you can be
guilty but you can't convince a jury
beyond a reasonable doubt and so
especially when the person is a super
loved hero for everyone even even find a
jury that doesn't know yeah and all of
his alleged victims are testifying in
his favor yes okay so nothing was found
that's false he was tried for four
months and found not guilty that's true
but it doesn't mean he's innocent he was
found exactly not couldn't even get him
on a misdemeanor
well he wasn't tried for a misdemeanor
you idiot even now the law works like
that's such a weird point it's not like
whoa he's not guilty of abuse let's try
him for a petty theft it's gonna for
jaywalking yeah the reason why we defend
him is not because we are fans okay sure
we are fans because we have studied the
deposition testimonies and court
documents instead of tabloid headlines
I'm sure that everybody sharing this
grandpa Simpson meme has studied the
testimonies depositions and court
documents first accuser was caught on
tape saying he wants money that was the
dad actually right yeah and I mean we
the other day we listened to the tape of
the dad and you know it you could easily
interpret it as being somebody that's
greedy and after money but if you listen
to it you can very much equally
interpret it as a furious parent who
wants to destroy the person that did
this to their kid you really it's all in
you know what beat you however you
interpret it
this is a flat-out lie first accuser was
caught on tape saying he wants money
false it was his father not the accuser
right the boy emancipated himself from
his family never spoke to them again
that's true
but imagine when if your parents sell
you into a child abuse you would want to
do that as well second case was filed
with time line contradiction and gaps
okay Sherlock Holmes
they had scammed other celebs like Jay
Leno I don't know what that means I am I
tried to find that I I'm lost on that if
anybody wants to send info on that I'm
happy to look at it but that that was a
weird one I was like what the [ __ ]
Wade Robinson and James safe Chuck are
proven liars who sued Michael Jackson
estate for money but when their case
were thrown out of court they decided to
make a movie know your facts fam okay
Adam so Wade Robinson was the dancer he
was suing Michael Jackson as we
discussed because he wanted to go back
on the stand and correct the record
James safe chuck was a child actor he
had a relationship with Michael Jackson
for a long time as far as I could tell
never sued Jackson never sought money
never sought any monetary damages or
compensation in fact he burned hundreds
of thousands of dollars of Michael
Jackson memorabilia that was given to
him and his family to be fair he did at
a late stage in the lawsuit join wait
that's what I so that's what I mean sued
that's what I'm getting to is that good
so Wade Robinson was suing him and I
think when they met and collaboration
for this what happened is that James was
living and still in denial you know not
knowing what happened but he was going
through a mental breakdown and he saw
Wade Robson talk about it on TV and that
kind of triggered him to come to terms
with what happened and right and so they
just they added him to the lawsuit as a
they just they just they just added him
basically to - so yeah so they they they
say their cases were thrown out it
wasn't thrown out on the merits again it
was a technicality passed the statute of
limitation and they were not compensated
by HBO in any way shape or form
to be in the documenting so know your
facts fam and again please recall when
you see this on social media that
grandpa Simpson the raving lunatic
delusional conspiracy theory who has
lost his marbles is the one holding the
sign I don't understand this whole
movement of like oh you're just gonna
believe a documentary it's like sorry
but I don't really trust HBO I love it
everything they make well HBO is dating
like credible they have to go to so many
lawyers absolutely so many approval ago
they they're putting the whole company
on the line you know they say I always
hear people saying it's unvetted
unproven yeah right I don't know oops
hurdles to jump through to get cleared I
can look into stuff and I did and
nothing changed my mind but I'm also not
gonna pretend to really a person
qualified to look at FBI reports and
like analyze a lawyer stuff like sorry
I'm just not qualified well when when
the dog when I go to see a doctor and he
tells me something I trust him you know
I believe what he's saying you're only
her dealer from that doctor well and
what's wrong with the documentary I mean
a documentary is a source of information
as much as a book a movie a magazine I
mean it's a it's up it's a collection of
knowledge it's anecdotes and stories a
documentary and that is a movie made for
the purpose of spreading knowledge and
this one happens to be a good one it's
the first-hand account you can a lot of
people that were in the room with this
sometimes there are bad documentaries
and you're in town and you know I have
some intuition that I can trust HBO is
not a network that puts out some
tabloids let's put let's put it I just
don't understand this it's like a
movement now we're anti you just believe
we're you what people tell you or well
no it's it's a movement of like oh oh
that's cute you actually believe that
yeah I don't know well again I mean I
think it all comes down to this sort of
smearing of the of the subjects of the
documentary and in questioning of their
credibility which again I mean I won't
go point by
point through it right now because it's
really arduous but you know if all those
people are saying oh do some research I
encourage them you need to do some
research actually follow up on these
statements that you're seeing that are
trying to counter the narrative because
almost every single one of them are
highly deceptive in RNA that they're
worth and and a lot of the facts are so
much in dispute so much that nobody has
like there's one claim that I always
hear and that supports my claim that
Michael Michael was a child abuser by
the way before I get too deep in that
come one of you guys find out what was
originally on the sign I'm really
curious like that could be really
religion Allah I actually I've a glee
remember the original picture you know
what I was saying is that there's one
claim that the child that the F or the
police took pictures of Michael's penis
and that the child was correctly able to
identify a marking on his penis now we
were not able in any way to corroborate
or there's a lot of claims like that
that it's just how you can't possibly
know if it's right or wrong so I'm not
I'm not bringing that up that's not a
Honda spirit fact but there's enough
yeah I think to try very very clear
picture I'd love to see what was
originally written on that sign that
somebody said you know I'm gonna erase
whatever grandpa Simpson has and write
this and people accept that as fact I
really want to know was there
furthermore don't take my word for it
because I am an idiot okay and that is
but that is my point
you don't need to have a PhD in I don't
even know what they expect you to know
yeah to form an opinion on this yeah I
don't I mean that's how would you go on
with your life you can't you can't do
anything that if you have to question
everything
well I always found it so rich when
people I built my whole career on
sharing my opinion I have a very strong
opinion and when people agree they get
very excited and they laugh and they
love it and they feel like they're on
the same team but when they disagree all
the sudden it's ethan stick to comedy he
then is always wrong his opinions it's
like it's like dude I either needs to
stop sharing his opinion and stick to
comedy it's like I built my whole career
this is this is what I do this is what I
do you know but so don't take my word
for it okay for all of the discrediting
you see on social media among Michael
Jackson fans this movie received 97
percent on Rotten Tomatoes and among top
critics it has 100 percent now I'm not
saying that to sit to say that critics
are correct about everything I'm only
merely exemplifying that every movie
critic 97 percent and 100 of top critics
watch this their whole livelihood is
critias a judging the merits of a film
and they all said there's something
credible and compelling about this film
that it's worth watching 100 percent of
them said that so these are people who
is whole livelihood is judging films and
they are an unanimous decision that
there's something compelling worth
watching in these documentaries and
Louis Theroux recently again thank God
because sometimes I feel like I'm living
in crazy world here Louis Theroux one of
the most brilliant prolific credible
documentarians of all time he's truly
one of my heroes now you can say I'm
stupid and that I don't do research and
that he thing said watch the documentary
overall that means it's try saying
that's a Louis Theroux if you can't see
that Michael Jackson was a pedophile
after watching dan Reid's documentary
you are willfully blind and if you are
campaigning against it you're actively
colluding in the silencing of victims
what a brilliant tweet and of course if
you go down in the comments the top [ __ ]
it's like this ain't it fam yeah I
haven't seen the documentary yet but FBI
conducted 13 years of investigation
shocking wow I wonder where you got that
information every time I see it I cringe
it's like come on people like just start
no comment and response was I usually
agree with you Lily but on this one
it's like okay and the the second part
what he said about silencing victims is
just so true it's so important and
that's just what's so painful for me to
watch with the way people are just
talking [ __ ] about this to guys and in
general and the victims it's yeah so
they changed their story because they're
a victim
I mean you maybe you haven't been to any
experience like that but this is
something that is very common with child
abuse well and their main point that
they're clinging to is completely
dismantled in the documentary they
refuse to watch yeah that was kind of
what was so heartbreaking and so
frustrating about this is like the if
you're willing to go out in public and
attack and ridicule and discredit people
because on the other end what you are
defending is potentially one of the most
prolific child predators and that that
ever lived so horrific so if if you're
willing to go in public and defend
potentially one of the someone who's
committed the most heinous crime you can
imagine one of the most heinous crimes
you can imagine I think you owe it to
yourself to do as much research as you
can and that unfortunately I hate to
tell you includes watching this
documentary that has a 100% in around
tomatoes and is widely acclaimed by
documentarians but it's so true you are
can't paint you are campaigning against
you're actively colluding and silencing
victims it's so true
imagine you're one of his victims
watching this and you're aware you ever
come out and this is the response it's
like yeah I would never why and so
you're already going through so much
shade you don't need the whole word
shooting on you - yeah of course Louis
Theroux puts it so brilliantly and I
just such a huge fan
his were you guys able to find the
original mean I haven't been able to
find it yet the chat has been somewhat
helpful
I think they've maybe pointed me in the
right direction of the right episode
yeah so okay good the search continued
close I'm closing in good thank you Jeff
make sure you guys so that's kind of and
then I see this to which I mean it's I
hear I see people saying they've been
two hours they say to me oh damn they go
well I believe that Michael Jackson did
the crimes he's accused of but because
he's dead and can't defend himself it's
wrong to drag him um what are that
statement to me is profoundly dumb
because you're on one hand saying yes he
is committing the most heinous crimes
that he never lived the judge he never
got taken to justice for destroying so
many family and so many kids he never
got the justice he deserved and I and so
a one hand you're like he is a heinous
criminal but on the other hand he can't
defend himself so let's not talk about
it how do those two ideas coexist out
there don't I I don't I don't even know
what to say about it so if he was a huge
awful child rapist we don't deserve to
know let's not talk about it I would
like to know so important because one a
lot of people say well he's dead what
does it matter okay they're survivors of
his crimes are very much alive their
pain is very much alive that their
families that were ripped apart is very
much alive and to if we as a world in
abled Michael Jackson to commit such
heinous crimes if we were collectively
groomed and cast under his spell that is
something that we as a world need to
grapple with and understand and make
sure that we don't enable people to do
it again so now should we talk about him
should we let it go because he's dead it
doesn't matter
that is absolutely profoundly dumb May I
don't understand that it's what would
the way I see that is just it's kind of
like a Michael Jackson apology just sit
down right now it's like I don't want to
talk about it you're kind of still in
denial I don't want to talk about it I
don't want to think about it kind of
like he's bad right exactly
it's proof that they've been groomed
because don't want to talk about it
you're starting to understand yeah maybe
did do something wrong probably most
likely did but I don't want to talk
about it well let's not talking he's
dead I don't want to drag his name what
are you his best friend but you don't
owe him anything
I don't want to talk about it cuz he's
dead and I feel uncomfortable but what
do you owe him since when is that even a
thing what I don't want to know the
truth he's dead what does it matter
I don't track his good name he's passed
on he can't defend himself okay let me
speak for him I didn't do it there was
no ants hit me with that make a change
would you you got it there were even
more there we go for once am I
it's gonna feel real good this isn't
going very well but watching my lap oh
that's Stevie Wonder look sorry sorry
Stevie sorry Stevie what's that one song
about the uh someone to need me is that
is that Stevie Wonder as well yeah no
there's a Michael Jackson song about Oh
Oh night long how's it go
that's one Oh Ritchie no come on there's
got one dance dance with you all night
yeah oh not a robbery I wanna sleep with
you
oh I wanna touch your penis all night
don't ever tell your parents ever I like
that tie little butthole everybody I
want to sleep with you eh
all night three hands up you like wanna
lick oh my don't tell your parents what
happened because I love you
and you'll go to prison forever what
else your hands everybody did you get
your passport did you get your shots do
you want to come with me to Neverland
house to Poona glad to that I want you
rock with your dick out Oh night don't
ever tell anybody what happened ever
right right anybody let's chat enjoying
this so should I stop sushi babies
yeah I don't know yeah sorry no I mean I
just don't think you should put it out
publicly yet you got to put some polish
on that and you know little production I
want with you oh not if you love me
you'll stay in my bed I want to be with
you I don't want to Michael I wanna
sleep on the floor
the real question can you separate the
art from the artist yeah that's a tough
one in this case I think it's too fresh
yeah I can't currently listen to Michael
Jackson and I doubt that I'll be able to
for the you know it's such a shame
because like I said his music is just so
tonight yeah r.kelly I can live without
I believe I can fly I believe I can get
my passport papers before I leave to
America no currently I feel like I
cannot do because actually with the
documentary paints is a picture of a man
who his whole life and everything he did
revolved around his sexual deviance he
was a man who the music the act
performance the fame the magic
everything was a vehicle to get what he
wanted from these kids and I feel that
that's wrong I'm sure that that's not
true I'm sure he had love for the music
and he was either he was a he was a good
complicated guy a decent guy in many
ways a loving guy in any way yeah I mean
didn't he do tons for charity and all
that kind of absolutely that's the thing
with abuse I mean you could be abused by
your father you know the court can be a
good take anything away from it could be
a good guy still and do horrible things
of course it's it's really complicated
it always is right absolutely right but
for now I think that I'm not listening
out listening to Michael Jackson I
couldn't understand it when it's so
fresh
but yeah I think I personally am able to
do the separation like I'm not gonna get
mean out I think I need some time to uh
that's fair I don't think I'm ready to
listen to Michael Jackie my go-to like
my favorite one of my favorite directors
is Woody Allen which obviously has a ton
of baggage associated with him yeah I'm
not gonna not watch his movies because
of that though the movies to me it
stands on its own as a piece of art so
yeah that's right
I get it though well you know a lot of
people say about vogner right he wasn't
a Nazi sympathizer but it's been a while
now like more than sympathetic well he
was a Nazi yeah and he was a straight-up
not see people like vogner so I don't
know maybe in a couple hundred years I
can ride of the valkyries though it's
here
now what do you actually think that man
in the mirror was about I'm looking at
the man in the mirror I'm asking him to
not rape any kids think he was trying to
coach himself out of it and if you think
and a different I've got a bunch of LARM
in my doorway myself when people come to
take Dube away hey everyone put your
hands up
everybody put your hands up we've got a
special guest here tonight Michael
Jackson everybody was dead all right
special guests Michael Jackson everybody
round of applause incredible performance
were you able to find the grandpa Abe
meme I have not been able to find it and
Chad's been on it too unless unless I
missed it I'm so curious you know it's
something so good like somebody somebody
claimed a specific episode is actually a
treehouse tree house abhorred episode
you know the science says something like
totally nuts I mean that character is a
loon well that about
oh I maybe need to do this extreme
vapenation guys if you have submissions
for us and we estimate podcast at h3h3
productions calm we would always love to
hear you last a few episodes ago we
asked for vapenation and extreme places
and you all answered the call they
delivered river rafting in South
Carolina Courtney and Korey that's cute
better names a Courtney and Korey like
the same name yeah this is the seed bank
right yeah this is really cool
Greenland's event a rollin huggin suvat
Vontae rollin huggin so this is super
freakin cool it's in like some frigid
it's either in Greenland or maybe
Iceland Phrygian area that's always
frozen over they have a replica of every
seed of every plant species on earth as
a bank just in case you know look if the
world gets nuked and well attempt
it's like a it's an underground it's
just the door to a big bunker there's no
complex underground store like every
seed of every plant on the planet isn't
isn't that the coolest thing like
sometimes humanity's the cook does it
cool Michael Jackson's like sleeping
little boys and meanwhile some dudes
like I'm gonna make a seed vault Eiffel
Tower
Pablo Blas I think I was actually Tokyo
Tower
oh what a scam this is very beautiful so
shout out to Jordan god bless okay I
thought I recognized but love you anyway
same place apparently South Dakota hated
God well [ __ ] Papa blows baby hto anime
convention the most exotic place on
earth
yeah Megan shut up - Megan at the anime
connection I've heard that's the one of
the most dangerous environments to be an
on planet Earth brave the wilderness for
me Nick in South Africa don't slip
vapenation Papa bus and we've got in the
hospital battling pneumonia ELISA Papa
bless you of a quick recovery T of a
[ __ ]
Teddy fresh hat Ukraine Hannah Peace
Corps trip dude you're good person no
vapenation we're rocking Itay for a shot
well public bus to you and and your
mission there of peace vapenation on a
rock Pikes Peak Colorado 14,000 wait
that's not it is it
yeah yeah yeah that one's Pikes Peak Joe
Nepal Alice in the h3 merch throwing a
pop of less that's very nice
blown fat clouds everywhere he goes this
is Christian the Bolivian salt flats is
this the same person well shut up - this
dude - I don't know I don't know why he
didn't get a title sorry but Wow
alright and decked out you went all out
for this one huh Phil you just got
filled in washington d.c vapenation
really representing their approve of us
great lots of canyon shots Dana at the
Grand Canyon
dad sir Canyon babe Nash to you
Nikolai's at the top of the Burj Khalifa
Papa blessed man you guys spread the
love even - even - uh where's
that--what's akimbo in Dubai thank you
in Hebrew Canyon is a shopping mall
sorry
Canyon in Hebrew is a shopping mall
Canyon we should make a shopping mall
and the Grand Canyon I call it the
candor Canyon came near the canyon
Canyon
this guy is doing an SOS for flavor
Plains vape god I think it says know it
says vape call it cuz he's all babies I
get caught
god that's very clever Sam thank you for
a reputation we've got Axl that's a
badass name excellent Thailand on one
hand desecrating the holy site that
you're visiting and so I thank you for
that
so guys thank you for night for
contributing what a thrill I mean my
goodness somebody had a skydiving one
but it was the sound was bad and he's a
quick flash um I don't have a link here
do it but appreciate you - do we want to
watch Ian and Zach you both watch the
documentary tell me what you think for
Christ's sake Ian you always got hot
takes dead Thome
oh no no hot takes I thought it was
pretty disturbing okay I thought you
were gonna just cop out I mean you have
an opinion about it
well I can't post my Simpson being four
back here I just got a note from ela she
says my secret notes she said wrap it up
soon I need to pee ela you know pregnant
women their bladders get squeezed by the
expanding in their body so she has right
away while we were talking about Michael
Jackson the baby was kicking hmm Oh what
is that I don't know each do we want to
watch the Kanye soul playing first yeah
yeah let's wrap it up with something
joyous
can you narrate this because you're the
Kanye superfan Ian I swear to God goaded
is Ian and Dan switch spots yeah you
know what you have to narrate this
alright let's see what's going on back
there
there is Dan is out there on the maestro
dan is on the maestro mixing it up okay
and I'm gonna play this so you let me
know what we're looking at okay okay so
he was in Seattle doing his church
service at the adidas headquarters on
Tuesday then this was on the plane
flight back to Calabasas did he try to
the whole plane are these all strangers
no way
yeah he just inspired yeah this is all
his crew right I would believe so yeah I
like to imagine there's one guy who's
not kind of looks confused babe the
cameras on I'm sure they sound the way
too good I think this yeah yeah you know
this his gang probably weren't
performing at the church
I love how happy Kanye looks he's been
looking so happy
yeah thanks me happy yeah he's all
smiles do you really want me right do
you really want me thank you and
anything else you wanna add in now that
you're in the hot seat put the camera on
the end and let's let's talk the end
yeah boy when can we get a PowerPoint
there's not been a lot of spicy stuff
for a PowerPoint or are you being too
picky
yeah I think I'm very picky in tell me
you watched all three parts of the
documentary did you you went in neutral
is that right pretty much yeah and you
came out neutral I mean it's definitely
it's not
a difficult task for me to distance from
Michael because I'm not you know Michael
listener yeah it's it's interesting to
watch kind of removed to see because he
is a hero to so many people so watching
them struggle with that has been it's
interesting to dig into for sure but
yeah I'd it's more than likely some some
bad things happened more than likely you
already hear from me in the dome you can
call me stupid but you cannot call in
here that guy puts together powerpoints
like you've never seen already and thank
you thank you
you guys can switch off remember ladies
he is single and he's going to the
movies by himself which is so tragic and
adorable at the same time you can save
him should I give your Instagram name or
no you can find it easily dan is also
single as I is that right down yes dan
doesn't like girls too young what's your
bottom you're not too young but I mean
like what no Angie I mean eNOS is
younger Dan is older
dan your barrier for entry is 25 right
yeah that's that's a decent floor I'm 31
so I'm yeah right about and Ian is like
23 so there's a big you know yeah yeah
and could get some answers sounded funny
yeah okay fine I'll give you that I'm
just saying Dan is a very eligible
bachelor he's handsome he's gainfully
employed he's smart he's insightful and
he is very very single ladies very very
bad that's desperate yeah I am so
[ __ ] single Zach is taken right Zach
I am taking man and very in a very happy
relationship
alright well she's got to try so even
doing does she watch this after Yoshi
bit okay no she'll have heard that yeah
is there anything you want to say to her
Highland how you doing oh not as
romantic as the Frog Lynn says her name
Lindsay Lindsay Lindsay you got a great
guy and he's Lindsay those jackets you
make her fire it's gonna put that out
there jockey Dan you go watch movies by
yourself
I mean I have it's not a weekly
occurrence for me
is there anything adorable and cute
vulnerable you can share it's adorable
yeah it really is so sweet no there's
nothing there's nothing sweet about me
I'm I'm cold bitter and well that's it
what you're gonna Dana's single alright
let's wrap it up we've done it we've
seen it all done talked about it how did
we you know - goddamn it we did it I'm
sure people will be very torn
that's why our to see the like to
dislike ratio it's actually not that bad
well that first it was like 50% down but
yeah I feel like Michael Jackson Defense
Force can only do so much damage hey
like I said when you made that tweet
that's so controversial you go look at
the ratio mm-hmm it's still healthy man
thank like the likes to comments so and
I hey that's all that matters in life
really is like so what does the 12 year
old boy say when he's in bed with
Michael Jackson
no I'm not gonna do it alright let's
wrap it up guys we thank you and of
course my guys out there who are all
single no I I wish I could hook you up I
don't know how to help you
it started dating actually dating thing
kind of doping it hook you up with some
h3 fans singles let me call a b.call I'd
be down to host like a singles night
speed-dating where I'm on the mic and
I'm like I wonder how we can make that
happen
at any rate thank you guys so much we
have guests coming what do we have
planned a man yeah I don't think there's
anybody next week yet but I believe the
following week we have next up is Theo
von Theo von wonderful and require
you're also rific comedian after that we
have slow mo guys run after that yet I
am personally excited to
meet with Emma Chamberlain who confirmed
yes it's confirmed
Hey okay and so I am I'm a fan I like
her she's extremely successful up and
coming when she's already come up she's
not she's up and she's going up higher
Emer channeling very talented young lady
that about wraps it up my dudes have a
terrific weekend and remember to Jim
Aune
what is it Jim oh hey I think it's
Shambo what is your game on that's H in
there you don't want to know and it's
getting into the groove you're scatting
both okay thank you that well that's it
so love y'all
I love y'all so much but okay fine just
wrap them and bye everybody
you
you